profisport wird weiter gehen also die
fußball-bundesliga unter ahnung aber
jetzt wieder ohne fans die geisterspiele
die wir auch noch vom anfang der partie
von der letzten saison kennen und genau
darüber möchte ich jetzt sprechen mit
weiter streiten jetzt bei mir bei uns
aus der sportredaktion weiter wir wissen
alle schon die geisterspiele laufen denn
wir kennen es von der letzten saison
jetzt hat man sich schon fast wieder
dran gewöhnt dass vereinzelt auf den
tribünenplätzen doch leute sitzen
wie bitter ist dass jetzt tatsächlich
oder ist es jetzt beim zweiten mal nicht
mehr ganz so sehr weh
na ja es tut schon noch weh also den
vereinen in erster linie weil auch wenn
es nur geringe einnahmen sind es waren
ja höchstens zehn prozent der
kapazitäten geplant oder 15 prozent tut
es natürlich noch mal weh es kommt nicht
ganz überraschend
bayern zum beispiel hat dem fc bayern
und den anderen bayerischen
bundesligisten profivereinen ja ohnehin
schon zuschauer verboten das land
nordrhein-westfalen hat gestern borussia
mönchengladbach in der champions league
selbst 300 zuschauer verboten und heute
bekam auch borussia dortmund vom nrw
gesundheitsamts oder beziehungsweise
dann vom ministerium die nachricht dass
sie auch heute abend ging petersburg 0
zuschauer in 80.000 der kessel haben
dürfen also die liga ist es gewohnt aber
es ist trotzdem furchtbar was mir dann
als allererste eigentlich jetzt bei der
gastro dann auch mit durch den kopf
gegangen ist ist wenn man jetzt schon
nicht ins stadion geht das konnten die
wenigsten von uns diese begehrten plätze
bekommt hat man sich daran gewöhnt dass
man zumindest in der kneipe wieder unter
schutzmaßnahmen fußball gucken konnte
das wird jetzt ab montag auch nicht mehr
der fall sein das heißt für alle
diejenigen die kein abo haben heißt es
einfach keine fußball bundesliga oder
könnte es da vielleicht irgendwas geben
dass wir es doch im freetv sehen können
das ist glaube ich schwer weil sky ist
der rechteinhaber für den großteil der
live-spiele insbesondere für die
samstags konferenz die das begehrteste
objekte der bundesliga ist die würden es
nur sehr teuer verkaufen an ein freetv
inhaber aber was wird uns zur folge
haben wenn du sagst ja richtig die
wenigen dürfte ich mein stadion und die
kneipen sind auch dicht was passiert die
richtigen fußballfans rotten sich den
zusammen muss man sozusagen im
privatwohnung als auch verboten ist
jetzt eher was verboten ist aber gott
wer will dass alles kontrollieren ich
glaube
die infektionsgefahr in einem stadion in
einem zu einem drittel gefüllten stadion
mit abständen mit kontrollierten hygiene
konzepten ist weitaus geringer als wenn
alle leute zu hause mit sechs mann auf
dem sofa sitzen und sich das spiel
angucken
also ob es eine weise entscheidung ist
kann man bezweifeln
sie ist halt jetzt da die bundesliga
wird damit leben viele vereine haben
ohnehin ohne zuschauer einnahmen geplant
schon für den zumindest die hinserie der
saison also wirtschaftlich ist es zwar
ein rückschlag aber es wird die liga
nicht umkippen ganz anders sieht es aus
bei den sportarten die vielmehr von
zuschauern abhängig sind
eishockey zum beispiel handball zum
beispiel die haben nicht die hohen
fernseheinnahmen die leben ja mehr von
den zuschauern für die ist es jetzt ganz
ganz bitter ist muss man sagen
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schaue ich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren